And the first thing you get is this really terrible
plot with one big, tall bar. And that's because most people
guessed a kind of small number, but at least one
person guessed 10 million people, saw my post, which was not
true. The first thing I needed to do was adjust
the axes so that I could actually see the bulk of
the data. So, I cut this one outlier out. And
then, I looked basically at people who guessed a few thousand
or, or below. Then, then you get a slightly better histogram by
adjusting the axes. And, you can still see that the bulk of
the data was in the smaller ranges, but it still was kind
of hard to, to see how large people thought their audiences were.
>> Moira just explained how she encountered an outlier in
her data. And I want you to think about what
type of outlier do you think it was. So, try
answering this question. Do you think Moira's outlier was an example
of bad data about a non-extreme case, bad data about an extreme case,
or was it good data about an extreme case? Choose the best answer here.